look pops and i we've been worried about
all these sudden changes we know that
you're worried about the changes the
family's going through it happens to
every family but i'm telling you this
terrible feeling you're having right now
it's not permanent it'll be over in four
years maybe eight but it's but
but you know
it's there's an old saying in the family
it's like a grandfather clock exactly
life is like a grandfather clock maybe
the pendulum is swung all the way to one
side but before you know it it'll swing
back to the other
hello
that was four years ago
comedian stephen colbert
and now man pretending to be president
joe biden doing comedy
lordy lordy it is june 23 2022 i'm dave
rubin this is the rubin report we are
live streaming on rumbleblaze tv on
youtube please
subscribe to our channels share the
videos et cetera et cetera we've got a
reuben report locals community q a for
you today it is a big mixed bag of
interesting things of political nature
of cultural nature of personal nature
all sorts of stuff uh i am just a few
minutes off being electrocuted by a
woman that i don't know that's right i'm
in the middle of getting some therapy on
my shoulder and uh i just walked into a
place woman electrocuted me and here i
am so we'll see what happens uh quick
reminder guys uh miami
july 14th i will be there i hope you'll
be there too daverubin.com
events uh we're gonna do a live reuben
report and uh it will be a blast i
assure you all right so i want to do one
story before we get to the uh q a today
you know i haven't done anything really
on this january 6th farce the whole
thing's a farce nothing's going to come
of it all of these crazy people on the
cable channels that are talking about it
they're just enraging people even more
they're enraging the enraged class
they're outraging the outrage they're
upsettingly upset they're only doing it
for views they know nothing is going to
come of it trump is most likely going to
run anyway they tried to impeach him 20
times it's all just theater it's like
the show must go on
nonsense but the reason i'm even
mentioning it right now is because the
last week
a group of comedians once again using
air quotes who work for stephen colbert
who is a late night tv show host he
replaced david letterman who was a
comedian that you didn't need air quotes
for
he is not number one in late night by
the way that's greg gutfeld over there
on fox who has like three people that
work for him and he's doing a great job
uh anyway a bunch of comedians who work
for colbert uh they in essence broke
into the capital they did not have any
clearance to go into the capitol they
broke in and uh insurrection people
insurrection we've got some more info
from the daily wire new details emerged
late on friday evening about the
staffers who work for cbs's the late
show with stephen colbert that were
arrested for allegedly illegally
entering an office building for the u.s
house of representatives nine
individuals were arrested on thursday
night for entering the longworth house
office building which was closed to the
public at that point after they
previously had been escorted out of
another building for trying to conduct
interviews related to the january 6
committee hearings the group has
apparently then roamed the house office
buildings unattended for hours pergam
said they were arrested near the office
of representative lauren bobert from
colorado around 8 30 p.m and charged
with unlawful entry they were in jail
part of the night before being released
on
friday now i should tell you in full
transparency i actually know two of
those guys i used to do stand-up comedy
back in new york with two of the
arrested comedian and frankly neither
one of them were funny and probably
should have been arrested years ago but
tucker carlson
over on fox news which is the only cable
news channel that people are actually
watching he just demolished colbert and
i said to the guys we have to show this
because it is
jeff's kiss beautiful
so how is what stephen colbert did
different from what the protesters on
january 6th have been convicted of doing
that's a very good question and it's a
question that colbert himself spent the
weekend thinking about his conclusion
well
unlike trump voters stephen colbert is a
very good person therefore any
comparison to trump voters is not simply
ridiculous it is a moral crime
watch
now it's predictable why these tv
talkers are talking like this on the tv
they want to talk about something other
than the january 6th hearings on the
actual seditionist insurrection that led
to the deaths of multiple people
and the injury
of over 140 police officers but drawing
any equivalence between rioters storming
our capital to prevent the counting of
electoral ballots and a cigar chomping
toy dog is a shameful and grotesque
insult to the memory of everyone who
died and it obscenely trivializes the
service and the courage the capitol
police showed on that terrible day
yeah
it was a toy dog it's shameful in other
words when you criticize me you're
really criticizing the brave capital
police officers who arrested the people
who worked for me the ones who committed
the crimes i asked them to commit and i
for one will not stand for that
that's what he just said
the shameful sedition it's like colbert
can't even emote properly he can't
balance that line between comedian and
human where he sounds genuine when he's
trying to tell you about the people who
are killed and everything else we
thought we'd flash back to this real
quick this is stephen colbert after
january 6 he's very emotional
now what you have there is not so much
an explanation in fact it doesn't
explain anything instead it's a master's
class on whiny rich liberal
self-righteousness it's a distillation
of a worldview that is so concise and so
perfect it is certain to be studied by
cultural historians of the future
seeking to understand how our
civilization collapsed
not only am i not sorry you're the
criminal for bringing it up stop hitting
me he screams as he punches you in the
face
that is
passive aggression taken to the level of
art and anyway colbert says shut up i'm
his i'm a comedian with a toy dog you
can't criticize me
so the question really is is stephen
colbert a comedian
my bad on that i got caught up in
tucker's actual emotion uh that was
further destruction of of uh colbert by
tucker now here's stephen colbert crying
he's overwhelmed after what happened on
january 6th
and if you did not know that joe biden
was getting close
to 270 donald trump just provided all
the proof you will ever need
true story i'm wearing black tonight
because i was getting dressed this
afternoon
and i thought he might try some
shenanigans and it might be fitting to
tell jokes while wearing something
somber if he goes down that dark path so
we all knew he would do this
what i didn't know is that it would hurt
so much
hold it together
what i didn't know was watching that was
gonna be so painful for me and the whole
crew here everyone's crying
so sad what happened to comedians after
january 6 because of the orange man
by the way guys there was another
interaction yesterday you're not going
to see this one on cable news this one
from
madison wisconsin the capitol building
over there
was stormed by left-wing protesters
[Applause]
remember when they bust into a capital
when they take over a building when they
violate the law et cetera et cetera it's
all good it's just when you scary racist
white supremacists do it that we got to
have all sorts of hearings and liz
cheney gets her panties in a bunch uh
all right we're going to get to the
reuben report locals community q a let's
just talk about start mail real quick
you ever wonder how big tech knows so
much about you i got three words for you
free email services when you click
accept on those terms and conditions
you're giving that email provider the go
ahead to scan and analyze your email
free email services or data orders if
you're done letting big tech make
billions by selling your info in your
email i suggest switching to start mail
start mail keeps your email private
period every email can be encrypted even
if the recipient
doesn't use encryption when you delete
an email in start mail it's gone forever
and start mail uses their own servers
not amazon's which means they can't be
put out of business if you're already
dropping big data hoarders like facebook
and jumping onto less censored platforms
perhaps like locals then right now is
the perfect time to switch to start mail
switching to start mail is seamless too
you can easily transfer all your current
email data so there's no starting from
scratch start mail is backed by the most
stringent privacy laws in the world you
get unlimited anonymous aliases so when
you're given your email to a company but
you want to protect your identity start
mail can generate a shareable alias
email so people can't sell your info and
they can be deleted at any time i keep
saying the way forward is to build
competitive businesses that support our
privacy values which is i which is why i
value the service that start mail
provides your cyber security has never
been more at risk email snoops and
scammers are taking advantage of the
pandemic as fishing has skyrocketed in
the last year
keep your private information private
with start mail sign up today and you'll
get fifty percent off your first year go
to
startmail.comruben that's s-t-a-r-t
mail.com reuben for 50 off your first
year start mail.com reuben and now back
to me all right reubenreport.locals.com
community q a ann marie says what are
your birthday plans
for this weekend that's right it is my
birthday june 26th this sunday
well i've been told that i don't know
all of the plans that there may be some
sort of surprise cooking uh but i do
know that the the crew uh we're going
out to dinner tomorrow night you guys uh
ready to eat some food drink some drinks
have some cake everybody okay uh we're
gonna do that there's a restaurant not
too far from here that we checked out a
couple weeks ago that was pretty swank
nice outdoor situation uh so we're gonna
do that and then honestly my house is
just under complete construction right
now there is drywall freaking everywhere
windows are down and
doors are off the hinges and there's
it's just paint everywhere is just a
mess so try to clean up a little bit and
hopefully we can get some pool time and
relax and then yeah i heard that there's
some kind of surprise on the way maybe
one other dinner maybe i'll see my my
sister and the kids and uh you know 46
years old i've done this 45 times what
do i need at this point i honestly i
have every i don't even need anything
like i'd like to go to home depot
that's all i do anyway i go to home
depot i just take little trips to home
depot maybe i'll get them maybe i'll get
a nice uh succulent that would be nice a
nice succulent that would be nice
rimfire says is there anything you miss
about california i'm getting so fed up
lady about two blocks from me was
stopped at a light and a car pulled up
next to her
uh and a bunch of men all dressed in
black broke her window and stole her bag
and these people still voted for soros
back d.a bechten
honestly there is nothing that i miss
about california there is nothing that
isn't to say that there's nothing good
about california like i really did love
wine country there was a time that la
was kind of cool the first time i went
to san francisco like 15 years ago it
was cool
but there was nothing left the crime the
homelessness the home the encampments i
mean michael what did santa monica smell
like when we spent that day on tour we
had the off day we went to santa monica
for the day what did it smell like
crap i thought you were gonna say urinal
cakes but yes it smelled like a
combination of crap and urinal cakes not
just urine but you know when you go into
a bathroom that other smell where it's
urine but it's covered up by the urinal
cake smell and then it's almost a worse
smell that's what santa monaco which was
one of the most beautiful
spectacular places a place that anyone
would want to live like your dream would
be to live in santa monica i think
three's company jack ritter and the gals
i think they lived in santa monica it
was a pretty great place mr furley he
could have lived anywhere the ropers
they didn't have to live there they
could have chose anywhere they chose
santa monica the whole place is a dump
and and on top of the taxes
and i just love florida did you guys
know that i love florida i love florida
there was a lizard i went to make the
coffee this morning it was a small
lizard running around the kitchen and i
thought i love florida
vika says in your opinion why do people
post still post apologies fake apologies
on twitter when everyone knows it
doesn't work yeah we covered a little
bit of this earlier in the week when
rayne wilson from the office he
apologized because he made a trans joke
and then james patterson
apologized because he said that white
writers are being discriminated against
in the literature
industry
i don't know why anyone does it at this
point i guess people are so lost you
know one of the things is that that
leftism and cancel culture and this
whole thing has become an endless
hostage situation so i think it's
something like this imagine you have
like 20 people in a circle and everyone
has a gun next to somebody's head so
everyone has a gun right and everyone
has a gun next to someone's head and
it's like everyone's just waiting for
someone to shoot first and i think one
of the things that happens with the left
is if you've been part of it if you've
canceled people if you've called people
nazis and bigots unjustly um you know
it's not fun so you you do it to
yourself sort of so these people they
live in this world like did rayne wilson
honestly
he made some joke about chest feeding or
something and then his apology was like
he's so sorry and he talked to his trans
friends and it's like you probably don't
even have any trans friends and even if
you did that doesn't mean your apology
is honest or worthy of making in the
first place or anything else so i don't
know
why do they do it like these people are
just pathetic like people are afraid to
stand up for themselves
you know it's not that you should never
apologize like i assure you i've
apologized many times in my life i don't
know if i've ever apologized
for something that was not worthy of
apologizing for that that's worse
right like if you do something wrong if
you really wrong somebody you steal from
somebody you cheat from somebody you act
dishonestly then you can apologize but
apologizing to an amorphous mob because
a bunch of twitter bots and loser
genderless whack jobs and anime freaks
on twitter are upset with you
i will not do that
shmu says dave borrowing any unforeseen
circumstances i think it's pretty
certain that president trump will run
for the presidency in 2024 currently the
only two men in the republican party
that stand a snowball's chance in hell
of getting elected to that office are
president trump or governor ron desantis
i like either one
what do you think of the 2024 trump
descent this run well look as i've said
first off i agree with you trump is
running
from everything i have heard from every
indicator out there trump is running i
think he's going to feel doubly
energized now that this january 6th
thing just you know fizzled into nothing
it was it's just like the impeachments
they get their panties in a bunch and
then nothing comes of it they look
stupid they feed uh they feed him it's
like just throwing raw meat at the guy
right so trump is gonna run now there
are reasons that it would be good if
trump runs he is still a force that is
undescribable in a way what he can do
culturally
and get people out there and get the
base fired up and all of those things
like i don't know that anyone else can
do that including desantis the fact that
the media hates him so much the
firestorm
but it's also a little bit of this it's
like we know we're all sort of on the
slow descent to hell right now this this
administration the media the whole thing
they're just slowly dragging us to
leftist socialist hell
trump coming in is sort of opening up
the gates to hell now i think you can
argue that maybe they should be opened
up because it's like the slow descent to
hell is no good the slow decent hell is
sort of like the frog in the slowly
boiling pot you don't even know once
you're cooked right once they're making
you into frogs frog's legs
to rip it all open again get the stuff
out there and maybe give these guys the
the kill shots so to speak i mean that
as a metaphor uh of really defeating
this [ __ ] the cancel culture stuff
like trump is probably the best to do
that now that being said trump has a lot
of problems too trump has a problem
which is that if he believes that the
election was stolen which he does
i've heard him speak about it firsthand
just a couple weeks ago at mar-a-lago i
mean the guy obviously does it's like
have you done the work to ensure that
they won't steal it from you again if
that's what you believe and i don't know
that he has does he has does he have
enough people behind him effective
people uh to run an administration more
effectively than last time i don't know
um the other problem i think this is
really his biggest issue and these are
not things that are insurmountable these
are just things that need to be said so
that they can be dealt with is that the
amount of hate that people have for him
which i think is mostly unwarranted
obviously if he runs i would say
probably five million people i don't
know that we can get an exact number on
this but i would say roughly five
million people who either wouldn't vote
because they're so depressed by biden or
they just don't care to vote or they're
on the fence or whatever just out of
hatred for him will vote
that's an issue that really is an issue
now the desantis thing it's like
desantis has proven himself to be in
essence i think you could argue that he
really is he's not the president of the
nation by title but he has been the
leader of the nation for the last two
years he has been the leader of
defending freedom he has run this state
brilliantly he's in the middle of his
own reelection situation he has a ton of
money
he's done it right he doesn't care about
the media stuff he's effective he's
hired the right people around him he has
an incredible staff
so he has all the pieces there
the of course the the
unknown is how do they come to some kind
of agreement do they have a sit down do
they have a private moment at mar-a-lago
or up at the governor's mansion in
tallahassee and figure out what are we
going to do
are you going to run for vp are we going
to make some agreement here
do i do it one more time and then you
come in after four years like
maybe the best situation that's probably
what i think is that trump is the is the
body man he's the linebacker pushing
everybody out of the way fighting the
media running the rallies doing all that
and desantis is the running back and
goes right through and scores the
touchdown that probably makes the most
sense
point being biden sucks the democrats
blow i think we got a chance
kobalt says how many different areas of
florida have you traveled to and what
was a memorable thing about each area
you know i've been pretty much
everywhere mostly southeast florida
obviously because that's the area i am
but i've been up to tallahassee
i've been up to orlando spent a lot of
time on the west coast in sarasota
that's where rumble and locals are now i
love the southwest beaches like the
naples area there is a beach on that
side i don't want to say what beach it
is because it's just remote and quiet
and peaceful and i don't want everybody
getting there and ruin it for me uh but
uh i do love the vibe of southwest
florida florida it's a little more calm
pleasant you know you're on the gulf
side not on the atlantic side so the
water's a little bit different was there
a couple weeks ago just really warm and
pleasant not as wavy um i just love
florida i love her the only area that i
haven't been to yet and i've never been
to in my life is the panhandle i just
haven't been up there yet it just hasn't
worked out yet but i know there's some
gorgeous beaches up there people keep
telling me that i got to get up there i
would like to visit pensacola because i
love the movie contact and as you know
when she meets the aliens it's in
pensacola of course you know that so it
would be good to go to pensacola but i
just i love everything about florida aye
florida
love you
casey says the ultra left is getting
crazier and crazier yes it's true is it
possible that some of them are agents
provocateurs
well that's what it always comes down to
with them there's always this debate
it's like how many of them are just
useful idiots like these the the gender
pronoun kids
and you know the the sort of 16 year old
or the antifa
drug addict whack job like they're just
foot soldiers that are useful idiots who
are being manipulated then you have
people like aoc who are just i think
actors and you know they just want to
destroy things because they're
self-absorbed socialist collectivist
weirdos um then you have like the true
believers in in that world view so you
have like a bernie sanders is like a
true believer in communism and socialism
i don't think he's faking it i think he
actually just believes in these bad
ideas but i think it's a big combination
and in some ways i don't even think it
matters i mean that's why i always bring
up the road to hell thing it doesn't
matter if your intentions are good if
your intentions are good
but the results are always evil the
results are always more destruction more
poverty more homelessness more crime
more cities burned to the ground less
freedom then i don't care if you're
intentionally doing it unintentionally
doing it you know the best we can do is
model a better life for people so
eventually as they've just wallowed in
their own crapulence as mr burns would
say as they've done that long enough
they might look over there and go boy
you know that other group of people
those red state people the florida
people the texas people the tennessee
people
those conservative leaning people boy
they seem happier and they usually wear
clothes that fit and they seem like they
have jobs and they get their hair cut
every now and again and they have
girlfriends and boyfriends and families
and dogs and they're not always
screaming about everything and they
smile every now and again and they
seemingly are doing something okay maybe
i'll look into that
so that's how we defeat these guys but
yeah i'd say it's a it's a combo of
bad guys bad actors grifters it's like a
whole mixed bag of things
purdue says if you could interview any
two people who would you want and uh i
noticed before we started the show we
already had an element ready for this
one you dirty dog you guys may remember
this
yes that is what that's got to be like
four or five years ago uh that is blair
white to the left uh trans advocate i
guess blair white you could call her and
candace owens who was that's like
pre-candice owens candace owens when
candace owens was uh she was a youtuber
known as red pill black there was some
controversy around her at the time
surprise surprise with candace and i
moderated this debate between the two of
them if you have not seen this and
you've got some time today and a bottle
of booze you should watch it i mean
basically they just scream at each other
for two hours and you can see i'm just
looking back and forth like what have i
done with my life however i will say it
ended up being a great day because it
was the first time that i ever trended
on twitter the hashtag save dave because
people we were live streaming it and
people were just watching me like what
am i doing
so i trended on twitter that was fun and
uh you know look candace has become a
very dear friend to me it was it was
just like one of those moments it was
one of those moments i woke up that
morning i thought we were going to have
like this interesting debate and it
devolved into craziness so i've already
done the interview of two people that i
would like to who would i really like to
sit down if i could have two people well
i'll flashing back to the previous
question right now if there was one two
people that i could sit down with and
actually do some work with it's trump
and desantis obviously and it's not even
because i think there's even tension
between them i don't i actually don't
think there is my guess is they probably
really like each other i think maybe
trump has a little bit of jealousy
related to desantis or something but i
think they basically they want to live
in the same country they want to fight
for the same things for the most part um
but it needs to be hashed out and since
i like both of them i've interviewed
both of them man what a great sit down
that feeling guys let's just work this
thing out let's look at the real
enemy here the real problem here let's
take that thing out let's build a great
country and uh you know just because
only one person could be called
president and again i say all this not
even knowing if
trump wants to be president again
there's no doubt about that i have no
idea honestly no idea if desantis even
wants to do it i know the guy loves
florida and wants to keep fixing florida
and i can tell you as a new floridian i
want this state to stay strong and the
state in many ways your state
means more than than the it doesn't mean
more than the country but if done right
america done right what happens in your
state will affect your life more than
what the federal government does and we
should all be focusing on that
janzi says hey dave the more i see rand
paul the more i like him what are your
thoughts on him doing a presidential run
or vp for someone so first obviously i
like rand paul a lot right rand paul is
as close as you are going to get to a
true libertarian in the united states
government he does not want the
government doing much he does not want
us going to wars he wants low taxes he
does not want a surveillance state he
cares about civil liberties he cares
about the constitution obviously i've
interviewed him many many times he's
welcome on the show anytime so sometimes
they just call us and they say hey
senator paul would like to talk about
something you've got 15 minutes that's
why we've been doing all these
interviews with him
so obviously i think he's a great guy
and and he cares about the right things
you know he's run for president at least
once has he done it twice if i'm not
mistaken it was all it was only one time
it was 2016 was the only time so 2016
when trump was running he was running as
a republican and if you remember like
you know they had ted cruz running and
marco rubio and a whole bunch of other
people and of course his father rand
paul uh ron paul ran twice before that
and really was sort of the the original
bernie in terms of like a grassroots
movement it happened to be on the right
so they called it racist and everything
else um but
he was up there when trump was running
and he was talking about all of the
libertarian stuff and what i always felt
about him was i couldn't really there
weren't a lot of jokes you know would i
be live tweeting the debates and stuff
there weren't a lot of jokes i could
make about him besides his hair is a
little funny uh it was mostly like oh
you're just kind of on the wrong stage
because as a as a libertarian you know
you're not exactly what a republican is
but i can tell you as someone that is
sort of new to this side and as you guys
know i'm i'm a newly registered
republican here in florida the the
republicans the conservatives they need
a strong libertarian wing within the
party so he has that work to do there i
would include ted cruz close to that as
well he is more on the libertarian side
of the conservative party that's strong
it's something i really deeply care
about
but to directly answer your question my
guess is he's not going to run for
president again i don't think he would
honestly see a path to the presidency
however
would i absolutely love him potentially
as vp probably i don't think they would
go for him on that either
but would i love to see him in the
administration whether it was a trump
administration or desantis
administration or whatever yes of course
could he possibly be something like
attorney general probably um are there
there are many many ways they can uh use
him and by the way one of the reasons
that i really came around to trump was
because
rand paul became one of his biggest
defenders so over the four years that
trump was president rand paul was often
out there
doing the anti-war stuff
doing the low tax stuff the state's
right stuff and was defending trump and
i was like well let me get this straight
the all right i had my reservations
about trump early on obviously but the
one senator who i agree with the most in
terms of the things that i care about
the most he's his biggest defender so
maybe there's something there so yeah we
shall see
nick says how do you get so lucky how
did you get so lucky as to meet the love
of your life
on your birthday of all days it must
have been the best gift to find a
partner in this brave new world to help
navigate your journey through politics
with and now fatherhood ps happy early
46. yes it's true dave and i met on my
birthday i think it was
13 years ago it'll be 13 years ago on
sunday we actually
met on my birthday wild believe it or
not i'm not proud of this part it
actually was at
new york city gay pride
okay and i just want to be clear about
something first off gay pride should not
be a month gay is not something to be
proud of either either is straight uh
but there were at some point before
marriage equality and all that it was
very different it wasn't about chopping
off penises and chopping off boobs and
all of the weird [ __ ] that it's about
now and gender pronouns and everything
else there was a sense of like fight for
marriage equality let's get us to be
equal and then let's move on so me and
my life i've moved on the people that i
associate with who happen to be gay have
moved on it's only these activist freaks
and the whack jobs in the media and the
lefty politicians who are pushing this
stuff so it used to be sort of a
celebration and a place to meet people
and things like that and yes we met
at uh it was at cowgirl bar
in the west village on gay pride and
david was wearing an american flag uh
tank top so it was meant to be it was
meant to be
elinda says hello dave linda from
virginia here if you were granted only
one wish
one order what would you change in our
government right now that would make a
huge impact for our country oh there's a
lot of ones that i could do there but i
would demolish the department of
education gone tomorrow
like that you all
you don't have to go home but you can't
stay here you people have ruined so much
of the country so much of everything
that's wrong with everything right now
it starts with education kids don't know
what basic liberties are they don't know
about the constitution they don't know
basic math anymore we talk we talk to
them more about gender and sexuality
than having financial literacy i mean
just the freaking basics the idea that
there is a department of education a
federal department that is overseeing
state education is crazy and by the way
it's crumbling in real time as we speak
and there are many many states now that
are starting to fund students instead of
funding systems which is wonderful
meaning you'll get some money as a
parent and if you want to send them to a
you know a public school so be it if you
have good public schools in your area as
i did growing up and i only went to
public schools or if you want to send
them to a private secular school or a
private religious school or whatever it
might be and by the way you know the
supreme court
is laying out a bunch of uh
uh
verdicts this week basically a bunch of
the the answers to what's all these
questions that we've got right now and
it's possible that the roe v wade
thing is going to be resolved tomorrow
which uh well resolved not really result
we'll get an answer on it and then the
fire will begin um but they did just
drop one yesterday about school choice
and they're gonna let people
once they fund the student if you want
to send your kids to a religious school
so be it so be it
and it's all good that's choice people
tony says dave put yourself in the
democrats shoes for a moment
if biden doesn't run in 2024 who do you
think they end up running so first off
there is no chance biden is running
there is no chance i do not think he
will finish the term we are only a year
and a half into this thing that means we
have two and a half more years of this
the guy barely can complete a sentence
it's a freaking disaster um i think the
progressives are happy about this
because everything that he's destroying
for them is the proof point that
capitalism doesn't work it's the proof
point that democracy doesn't work so i
think they are thrilled right now they
they are salivating they are chomping at
the bit that biden is destroying this
thing far faster than even bernie could
have destroyed it uh but
that being said they are going to be way
more radical so it's like
the obvious choice is okay they just
throw kamala out there um my guess my
guess because we're in the show must go
on version of democracy right now you
just need things that feed the beast you
just need things that keep eyeballs on
things so that we can't think about
what's really going on my guess is it's
going to be michelle obama that really
would not surprise me they'll just slide
her in there everyone will start talking
about it and next thing you know biden's
too old barack's going to go on 60
minutes well he's lost a step or two and
next thing you know
that'll be that biden will be pushed
away uh hopefully they'll jail jill
biden because uh you know i think she's
basically a criminal at this point
because you know she's they've got him
on drugs right they've got him on drugs
there's no doubt about it so there is a
scandal here and the thing is the truth
you can't hide the truth you can't hide
the truth so one day when he's gone and
the system doesn't need him anymore it's
gonna take out a lot of people because
would it not be a massive scandal if it
was known that the president of the
united states has a mentally
compromising disease and it's being
hidden by a whole bunch of people
including his wife the doctor and
they're drugging him and they put him
down to bed at 3 pm and they let him
come out for a few minutes and how they
grab him away from reporters and all of
those things so my guess it'll be
something like michelle obama but you
know it could be gay pete could be gay
pete give me one more you guys got a
favorite democrat you want to throw in
there
oprah could be oprah connor give me
something
corey booker corey booker ladies and
gentlemen in case you want a guy that
just cries at the drop of a dime sandra
says we're going to be in miami area
next month looking for restaurant
recommendations we preferred laid back
verse fancy schmancy um
well as i said we haven't gone out that
much because we like to cook and uh
no i'm not going to tell them to go to
hillstone yes that's oh the only place i
go honestly i go to hillstone you know
hillstone it's houston's hillstone i've
talked about on the show once or twice
it's a it's a bit of a chain i just love
them that freaking hawaiian ribeye my
god there's nothing better on earth um
we've taken where'd we go for michael's
birthday we went to key club down in
coconut grove we did do that that's
that's a little more on the fancy side
i'll give you one if you want just great
pizza i know that people say you can't
get pizza in miami that's what they're
telling me oh you wrote it before i was
going to say it before you even wrote it
on there mister is it mr 01 right yeah
it's mr 01 pizza they've got one down in
coconut grove and i think they've got
one somewhere a little more north in
miami they have a pizza believe it or
not there's coffee on the pizza they do
coffee grinds and then they put honey on
the pizza and i get it it's not a new
york slice thrown at you by a greasy guy
eat your pizza it's not that it's a
little more
evolved but it is quite delicious and
you can sit outside or inside you'll dig
it mr 01 pizza uh big poppy
says given what we now know about andrew
gilliam what do you think florida would
have looked like with him at the helm
when coveted struck so if you didn't
hear about this so andrew gilliam is the
democrat
who ron desantis beat by 30 000 votes
for governor a couple years back
who not only turned out to be a meth
addict having orgies but he has now been
indicted like 30 counts in a federal
indictment and he's going to probably
spend a good portion of his life in jail
we were that wire fraud whole bunch of
stuff we were that close i mean 30 000
votes that is nothing we were that close
to this state
turning blue being locked down the exact
same way that new york and california
and a bunch of the others were and it is
by the grace of god and 30 000 people
that that did not happen and then what
happened is that ron desantis then did
the right thing i mean that the the
beauty of the ronda santa story is
although he was a congressman before and
he was in the military before and a
lawyer and all those things it's like he
really became a leader overnight and
became the guy that we now all know and
so many of you are supporting and
looking at is sort of the holy grail of
politicians uh not not in a worship way
because i know you guys like me don't
worship politicians but like oh there is
someone who's not
evil
involved in politics how refreshing
right um what do i think would happen to
to florida i mean i think it would be
exactly in the same place that new york
and callier and i think if you were to
look at the migration maps where we've
seen all of the u-hauls going from
cali going this way and all of the
u-hauls from new york going that way i
think you would have seen a lot of
people fleeing florida as well and i
think the economic situation would be
very different i can tell you that the
four of us in this room right now would
not be living here we'd be living in
tennessee guys
or we'd be living in texas yeehaw that's
what we'd be doing you got boots i'd
like to see you in uh michael you don't
have boots you don't have cowboys tell
you a funny story about cowboy boys
michael and i go to tennessee like a
year ago to nashville when the daily
wire moved out there and i said you know
what i'm on the daily wire i'm on
candace's new show tonight it was like
it was either her first or second show
say i'm gonna go
to uh to tennessee and i'm gonna go to
nashville and i'm gonna get cowboy boots
right everyone's got cowboy with so we
go to the main drag there in nashville
what's it called that main street
that main street and you've seen it
everyone's seen it you know it's sort of
like the times square of nashville and
there's a million boot shops we walk
into the boot shop looking at all the
boots i see this pair of boots i'm like
those are the boots that i'm gonna wear
so i put on the boots and i realized and
the woman was laughing at me i came from
la and in la you wear jeans that are you
know kind of tight to the leg the the
slim straight fit i don't go slim bit
like i'm a wafey 16 year old girl but
i'm doing a slim straight jean
and i could not get the boot on and then
for the first time in my life i
understood what the boot cut was i never
really put it together the boot cut
phoenix did you know this you're a
little younger did you know that the
boot cut is legitimately for a boot to
fit on your yeah
speaking of boots another thing that
happened was michael once broke his foot
and had to wear the boot you know the
boot when these people are when they
break their foot and we made a lot of
fun at him for that uh okay was it
christina's boots that was the name of
the store
christina she likes boots oh christina
likes boots who's christina
christina's a fan i'm being told that
christina who is a fan
enjoys boots
okay
robin says is david still planning on
creating his cookbook i'll be the first
in line to buy yes
there is a very preliminary version of
it out there you know because of the
move and because of the construction and
because of the babies and everything i
was like it's just getting delayed and
delayed we are working on it and i'm
going to see if maybe you know i want to
work on a third book which i've been
sketching out a little bit but i'm
thinking maybe i delay that so we can
kind of work on this thing together and
make it happen
but
yes he's working on it and if you have
not followed along i guess you have
but you can go to davidscookbook.com and
you can see his amazing whole chicken
that people love it's megyn kelly's
favorite chicken you can see the cast
iron pic chicken parm you can see some
some the not fried fried wings and a
whole bunch more talley says with your
annual off the grid barely over a month
away man
what a year
what are some of the ideas you have to
celebrate it in your new state of
freedom have you received any
invitations i mean first off i haven't
had a second to even think about it this
year we're not going to go away you know
we usually go away but because baby
number one is pretty close to being born
like we have to be close and you know
we're we've been spending money like
crazy with the rebuilds and babies
coming and everything else like we're
not doing anything crazy this year we're
gonna hunker down we'll hang out here
and then we're going to get the call and
the life will change and
uh and it's all good um so yeah we're
just going to kind of relax but i
haven't had a moment to think about the
off the grid thing this one will be a
little different than others david
usually does like mostly off the grid
with me he does it in terms of news and
everything else but he does check his
phone once or twice a day for family
updates that kind of thing this year
he's gonna have to have it on a little
bit earlier in case we get a call from
the surrogate or the ob gyn et cetera
i will not do any news i'm not going to
do any media intake or any of that stuff
but obviously there'll be a little bit
more maybe with phone calls and
congratulations and texts and that kind
of thing
but yes i will still come back september
1st not knowing anything that's going on
and as i've been saying probably they
say it ages you it ages you 10 years
overnight having a child so
did the best i could for as long as i
could you know really did
guys if you'd like to ask questions in
our next community q a you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com by the way
my stand-up special don't say dave it is
free for annual subscribers and if
you're an annual subscriber you get two
months free oh look at that with the
image you are on point today man uh so
you can go to reubenreport.locals.com
and if you want to just
buy the special one time only
it is 9.99 which you can do right over
there that is the content plus feature
that we built out on locals which is
really crushing it by the way that's
where uh dinesh d'souza launched 2000
mules and
i don't just talk about this stuff guys
we are building the alternate pipes of
the internet
tomorrow is friday so we've got a round
table extravaganza we've got libby evans
from post-millennial we've got chad
prather from the blaze and jeffrey
tucker uh who is a fabulous economist
who i've had on a couple times and i
said to my guys man he hasn't been on
for like two years tell you something
about jeffrey tucker you're gonna enjoy
him tomorrow watch my interview i've had
him on a few times but the interview
that i did with him like a couple weeks
into covid where he was one of the
people that got it right from beat one
you'd never give up your rights you do
not lock down you do not do mandates you
do not stop people from working you do
not close schools he just got it right
and i believe credit is due so i will be
giving him some credit tomorrow anyway
we got a cold clothes for you uh joe
biden ladies and gentlemen see you
tomorrow
try to remember what it was that first
got you involved
in politics to begin with i remember for
me what it was i got involved in
politics for two reasons only two at the
front end of my career
civil rights and the environment voting
rights
voting rights
voting rights that's how i got involved
in politics we ended that damn war
that's why i ran the vietnam war that's
what got me involved in politics in the
first place thing called redlining i got
involved in politics because of the poor
and the disadvantage i got involved to
try to stop the construction of that
highway which i did that's what got me
involved i quit the law firm and asked
for a job to become a public defender
that's what sort of got me involved in
politics i got involved in politics to
begin with
because of civil rights and opposition
to white supremacists the ku klux klan
it's all about family it's all about
community
and it really is actually competing and
she got him involved that's what got me
i got involved in politics because of
the neighborhood i came from the reason
why
i got involved in politics the reason
why the print that iran the president
got involved
is
the one primary role for government
is to protect people i was at the
signing the voting rights act has been
the only constant in my entire political
career that's what got me involved in
politics and i got involved because my
state was the only state in the union
when dr king was murdered
that was occupied by the national guard
i ran for public office because of
the burning
how can i say it
the almost bile that was in my throat
about
watching
bull connor's dogs on television
in the 50s these same issues relating to
what constitutes
decency and honor in this country
it's just a thing that got me involved
in public life to begin with the
confluence of those sort of
basic values the things everybody has to
overcome in their life and what you
in fact basically liked naturally all
seemed to in retrospect move me in a
direction
that
got me involved in public issues and
public life my political hero got me
involved in politics there's
a lot of great men and the two kennedy
brothers who are deceased were great
folks it's simple that's why i got
involved in the first place